and uh basketball is just not the most
important thing to me right now
there's a lot of stuff going on overseas
all my people are still in bondage
all across the world and there's a lot
of dehumanization going on so
you know i apologize if i'm not gonna be
focused on y'all questions you know it's
just too much going on in the world for
me just be talking about basketball
i got focused on this [ __ ] 24 7 most of
the time but
it's just too much going on this world
not to address you know it's
it's sad to see this [ __ ] going on um
and it's not just in palestine it's not
just in israel it's all over the world
man and i feel it
i'm very compassionate to all races all
cultures
and to see a lot of different people
being discriminated from
upon or against being discriminated
against
based on their religion color their skin
what they believe in
it's just it's just sad you know you
know we all say we're human beings and
we care
and we're compassionate but um you know
what are you doing to help
you know and being in this gym yeah i'm
grateful for opportunity it's a blessing
but
my goal out here my purpose is to help
humanity and i can't sit here
and not address that you know i don't
care which way you stand
on either side if you're a human being
then you support
you know the la the anti-war effort
that's going on there's a lot of people
losing their lives children
a lot of babies and um you know that's
just what i'm focused on so if you guys
want to ask me questions about the game
greetings and peace alhamdulillah
how are you my brother i am fine
alhamdulillah thank you so much for
inviting me brother eddie
historian academic somebody who's
dedicated his life
to speaking out against injustices
calling people to the purpose of life
have i left anything out
probably a bunch but is there anything
that you want to fill in
i think you've said too much
[Laughter]
a lot more can be said but what right
now
there is oppression media manipulation
it's so nice to see this is one of the
basketball players from the nba you guys
i don't know if you heard of the nba
many are silent but this is one
who we believe recently accepted islam
and he's like i
i don't have time for basketball right i
don't want to talk about basketball
while many of people are playing the
xbox little kids are getting blown to
pieces what do you think when you hear
someone like this
speaking out rahmani rahim
i find this to be very encouraging
people of influence people of following
people who have ability to speak they
must speak
it is a basic tenet of islam
to speak up when you see oppression the
prophet sallallahu alaihi salaam in a
categorical report
stated
an evil and injustice
then you stop it with your hand if you
cannot do so then
open your mouth use your tongue use your
speaking ability to speak against it and
if you can't do that
then at least consider it bad in your
heart
and that is the weakest of iman so to
see
people come out and speak up against
injustice oppression
this is very encouraging of course
people
who have the ability to do more must do
more
not everyone's a politician not
everyone's a general not everyone
is an academic not everyone's a public
speaker but
whatever ability you have whatever
capacity allah has given you
you know what it is use it for
the betterment of this planet we want
this
world to be a better place we want peace
and justice to prevail
and that for that reason we must speak
up we can't remain silent anymore
there's a lot of people who when they
see this this is just
blatant blatant injustice happening uh
you have people like uh
recently you had a paris hilton she
actually spoke out it's interesting
you know heartbreaking this needs to
stop
but then shortly while a little while
after her
tweet was removed so you have some
people
who suffered the backlash of speaking
out
so i want to start off with just making
this clear because a lot of times
the attack will come oh muslims hate
jews
oh the term anti-semitic comes out
even though in history so i want to i
want to go to this next
clip and just show
that there are actually many many jews
out there
who are actually speaking out against
this i want to show a few
clips and then get your reaction to this
with the help of the almighty
my name is rabbi israel david weiss
my name is heimbra sheet my name is
anat natasha kamran my name
is jonathan rosenhead my name is hagit
and i'm an anti-zionist jew and i am
an anti-zionist jew and i am an
anti-zionist jew and i am an
anti-zionist jew
and i am an anti-zionist jew
i support the full rights of the
palestinians
i oppose israeli apartheid
i'm against israeli racism and
discrimination
i am against the silencing of my voice
i am against the silencing of my voice
i am against the silencing of my voice
for this i've been called anti-semitic
for this
i have been called self-hating jew for
this
i have been called a traitor but that
won't stop me
but that won't stop me but that won't
stop me
let's be clear anti-zionism is
not anti-semitism jews and palestinians
are not enemies israel is not acting in
my name
israel is not acting in my name israel
is not acting immoral what brings you
here today
to support palestinian rights we as jews
are embarrassed what's happening there
in the state of israel in the jewish
name and what's your message to the
people of palestine they shouldn't give
up the struggle
they should continue to fight and not
give up the struggle against
against the state of israel because by
the end palestine will be free
because this is truth will succeed by
the end what's your message to the
people
i'm an american and i'm also someone who
holds israeli citizenship
i lived there for three and a half years
in my childhood and i was always told
that israel was only ever defending
itself that it was never the aggressor
that the palestinian people were
were always the aggressors and that they
only wanted death to all
jews and all of israel well the wool has
been pulled from my eyes
and it's not just what's happening now
it is what has been happening
from the open air prisons to the
checkpoints
to the blockades to the lack of human
rights
water electricity the covid vaccine all
of it
children being ripped from their
families homes being stolen by zionists
this cannot continue everyone must stand
with palestine
i stand for a free palestine
this must end and it must end now
that's very touching it's very deep what
what do you actually question what do
you think when you see that
fascinating absolutely amazing these
voices were suppressed for a very long
time
hence the statements that do not
suppress our voices
let our voices come out so so the world
can know that this is not
an anti-jewish movement this is a
movement against an extremist ideology
that wants to
wipe out an entire people from uh from
the face of this earth
so this is about confronting extremism
this is about confronting oppression
this is about speaking up against
those who do certain crimes in the name
of certain people and i'm so
happy to see the jewish voices to come
out to express
their views on this to let the world
know that whatever the state of israel
is doing to the palestinians is not in
their name
they are not involved they don't
sympathize they don't
even condone such barbarity in their
name
because the state of israel for a very
long time has been using
the name of the jewish people the house
of israel
as a trump card to suppress voices you
see this this uh
this accusation of anti-semitism comes
your way every time you open your mouth
to criticize the state of israel or the
zionist ideology
uh the the accusation immediately that's
thrown at you
is that you are anti-semitic not long
ago literally
less than 24 hours ago one of the cnn
journalists
she interviewed the pakistani foreign
minister and he
highlighted the fact that the media is
very very much
biased towards israel
and she had the audacity to tell him
that
you are making an anti-semitic statement
and he was shocked
to hear this that how can you um
how can you even attempt to call me an
anti-semite when
i am uh highlighting or i'm i'm pointing
to
a fact the fact is that the media has
been
very biased in its reporting when it
comes to
uh the state of israel and it's a pre
oppression against the palestinian
people
hundreds of children have died innocent
people
more than 250 innocent people have been
killed in the recent conflict
and it's not a conflict by the way it
cannot be called a conflict conflict is
between two factions here you have
an occupying military with immense might
and war machine against a people
who have slingshots who have stones at
best
you know what do they have they don't
have a military they don't have a state
they don't have
a political uh leadership that's
effective enough to stop this oppression
against them
so where is the conflict so i it is very
encouraging to see
voices in particular jewish voices
to speak up against the oppression of
israel so that we can all together
as brothers and sisters in humanity
stand together against this oppression
where wherever it may come from right
whether it comes from muslims
or christians or the jewish people we
need to stand against oppression
together
as brothers and sisters in humanity i'm
very very happy to see this
uh these these voices and these clips
let's go back into history you're a
historian now you can give us
some academic facts not fiction so
before we get into
educating people on the
blatant injustices some examples
the occupation et cetera et cetera let's
go because this is what we wanted to
start this
on the framework that this is not an
arab palestinian thing
a muslim a jewish thing
muslims for centuries
were actually the protectors of jews so
let's go ahead and let's hear and then
we get your comments on that
jews themselves this is something that's
from their academics from their sources
and let's hear from the lips of jews
from the past and today
who testified to this fact
jewish men and women and children
who lived in albanian lands
[Music]
now this is a very long topic i mean you
can go on and probably
write a book on this but just in short
can you talk about
these facts how jews were persecuted and
they were driven out of the christian
lands
the golden ages of the jews and how they
fled persecution
from the nazis and how from world war ii
even back before then and after that
how muslims were is this a true
statement i mean that muslims were the
protectors of jews
historically an academically sound
statement
absolutely brother eddie and this
statement has been confirmed
and verified by many jewish historians
and academics
this is not muslim propaganda this is
not something muslim historians have
been claiming
or muslim politicians have been stating
this has been clearly stated by jewish
academics they have acknowledged
that for over a thousand years when the
jewish people
were facing persecution they were in the
diaspora
and during this diaspora they were
scattered all over the world
and they were facing heavy oppression at
the hands of the catholic church in
particular
throughout christendom the jewish people
were oppressed for example to give you
one example
in the year 633 ce there was a council
held
a church council held in the city of
toledo in spain
this is exactly a year after the prophet
of islam passed away prophet muhammad
sallallahu islam died
in the year 632 ce a year after the
prophet's death
in the year 633 ce this council
was held in toledo and it was decreed
in this council that all the children of
the jewish people are to be taken away
from them by force and they are to be
raised as
pious christians by the catholic nuns
and monks
in other words the jewish people in
spain
were to give away their children by
force to be raised as christians
to be forcefully converted to
catholicism
this is why a jewish historian called
zion zohar who who is a contemporary
historian american historian in his book
a history of the sephardic and mitsura
jury on page nine he states that when
muslims arrived
in spain in the year 711 the jews
welcomed them as liberators
the jews opened the doors for them and
thenceforth for the next 700 years
the jewish communities in spain
prospered under the domain of islam
under the protection of islam
in fact there were times when jewish
influentials became prime ministers
there was a jewish prime minister to the
most powerful
caliph in the history of islamic spain
abdulrahman iii who governed in the 10th
century ce
he was the caliph in cordoba a rival
caliph to the
abbasid cave in baghdad he was the most
powerful monarch
in western europe at the time he was
ruling
spain islamic spain and london and he
had a jewish prime minister called hazda
how is that possible if muslims were to
pursue an anti-jewish policy
across the board all the way so this
propaganda or this perception that the
muslims
are bloodthirsty they are after jewish
you know lives they are uh you know
thirsty for jewish blood or we
want the jews to be destroyed or
something like that these are all false
ideas spread by the state of israel as a
deliberate policy
to justify their crimes against the
palestinian people they come up with
this propaganda
that the muslims are against the jewish
people muslims want
the jews to be destroyed and you know
this is this is not acceptable we have
to speak up we have to really talk about
the history if that's the case then what
happened for one thousand years
from al-andalus from spain to india
where the muslims ruled
okay this large stretch of land was
governed by the muslims
why were the muslims giving refuge to
the jewish people
in particular those jewish people who
were heavily persecuted
in christendom uh if you if you go
further into history
if you want to look deeper in 1215
the fourth uh council for fourth lateran
council
uh you know that decreed and it was held
in france
that was it was decreed that all the
books of the jewish people are to be
burnt
and because they are guilty of die side
okay thy side means they killed god the
jewish people were accused
of killing the christian god okay and
christian god
is allegedly jesus christ so because
jesus christ
was crucified due to a jewish conspiracy
uh as the
the gospels indirectly suggest uh the
jewish people were accused of that crime
and for that reason they were persecuted
heavily throughout european history
jewish scholars have written books on
this right uh there are so many books
there is one book in particular i
strongly recommend it
is authored by mark cohen mark cohen is
a jewish
historian he has talked about this uh
the jewish people under the crescent and
the cross
he talks about of course there was no
utopia there was no perfection there was
no
paradise so to say under the rule of
islam for the jewish people but the
jewish people themselves
called their experience under islam the
golden age
they called it the golden age of islam
and i have
uh the jewish historians themselves for
example
uh if you really want me to quote
certain people
i can put quotes out i mean let's start
with
um
let's start with a contemporary
testimony from a jewish rabbi living in
cordoba in the 11th century in 1080s in
cordoba a jewish rabbi called bahaya bin
pakhuda
he states in his states titled ketaval
hidayah
he states if one of our contemporaries
looks for similar miracles now
let him examine objectively our
situation among the gentiles are either
muslim
in this case since the beginning of the
diaspora
and the way our affairs are managed in
spite of the differences between
us and them both secret and open which
are well known to them
let him see that our situation as far as
living and subsistence
are concerned is the same as theirs or
even better
in times of war and civil disturbances
you see how both their leaders and their
vulgar
peasants toil much more than the middle
and lower classes among us
according to our lord's promise
contained in the scriptures
so here we have a jewish rabbi in
11th century cordoba writing about his
status his life and how
you know how prosperous the jewish
people are in comparison to the muslims
other muslims who may be written in in
the
in the in the 12th century we had
a jewish traveler who traveled through
baghdad his name was benjamin chidilla
benjamin todela wrote in baghdad there
are about 40 000 jews
and they dwell in security prosperity
and honor
under the great caliph at that time
caliph al-mustanjid
and amongst them are great sages the
head of the
academies engaged in the study of the
law he's talking about the
the iraqi academies of um
the jewish people you know some of the
best rabbis in the world
throughout the middle ages where were
they found
mainly two places if not more two places
if not more
number one the best rabbis in the world
the most educated the most thoroughly
trained rabbis in the world
or the jewish people who were guiding
the jewish communities around the world
were
in baghdad in iraq
ruled by the muslims for so since
there was no book burning like we have
modern time we have
people burning the books you know modern
day book burning
happening now in in this area this
wasn't happening at that time even
though the muslims had the upper hand
they were ruling
look as bayabin bakuda stated in his
you know the statement i read from him
he said the differences are known to
muslims
open and secret they know about us they
know about the jewish law they know
about
our beliefs and yet they do not they
don't persecute us we are living in
prosperity
so there were no book burnings in spain
there were no book burnings in baghdad
there were no book burning like they
were in the christian world
in the christian world the jewish books
were burnt they were wiped out
completely
in france in fact the jewish people were
banished altogether they were exiled
they were thrown out of britain in
the 13th century by king edward the
first and then later on the french king
at the same time he also banished the
jewish people where did they go
is the question where did they find
refuge they found refuge
in spain governed by the muslims at the
time
and what happened after spain fell to
the catholic monarchs in 1492.
in the year 1492 the last stronghold of
the muslims
called granada fell to the catholic
monarchs
where did the jewish people go then
because they were the most heavily
persecuted people once
spain fell entirely to the christians or
the catholics in this case
so the jewish people they left spanish
territory
for again the muslim lands they went to
the ottoman territory they took refuge
in telenika
in constantinopole and other
uh cities in asia minor they went as far
as india some of the jewish people went
they took refuge in the middle east they
took refuge in north africa some of the
jewish
migrants from spain were in morocco and
tunisia and libya
for until as late as 1948 when
the state of israel was created against
the wishes of
the palestinian people and it was only
then
when things became bitter when the
jewish people
felt insecure in the muslim lands
because
of the actions of the zionist movement
in the land of palestine
it was then uh when this cordial
relationship between the jewish
people in general and the muslims
uh in particular you know hold yourself
there
we're going to get to that in a moment a
couple more questions you have the
what's considered by the jews almost
like the second moses
um the moses uh uh
what's his name the uh maimonides
he was someone also who who uh
flourished
and he was considered like the second
moses
and if and he got educated in muslim
lands we can go on and on and on how
about this statement
by a modern professor have you heard
this statement
um islam saved jewry absolutely
this is in the jewish chronicles this is
in there i've heard this statement not
from one jewish academic
many one of them is bernard lewis who
was actually zionist himself bernard
lewis was
an adviser to the zionist state of
israel he also advised the white house
bernard lewis made this statement who
was a
historian also jacob lassner
is a well-known jewish historian a
jewish academic
in the us today he also made similar
statement
about the the fact that the muslims
saved
the jewish people from destruction they
were facing at the hands
of christendom at that time throughout
the middle ages
throughout the middle ages so this
statement doesn't come
it doesn't come as a shock to me i mean
it doesn't surprise me at all because i
have
i have a number of statements in front
of me from jewish authorities and
historians
who have stated some similar things all
right now if we go to modern day times
if you
watch something like this tell us would
your reaction be the same
there were 14 of them total six girls
and eight guys and uh they're hitting me
in the face
i'm bleeding on the ground my lid splits
open i'm bleeding and this random
stranger
uh hassan ascheri jumps in a muslim
american saved us
[Music]
what do you think when you see that
modern day time hassan jumps up to save
you know you see muslim history
is full of similar incidents muslims
have been
saving people wherever they could like
you mentioned earlier that during the
the second world war there were many
muslims who were saving or they were
doing the best
to protect the jewish people of course
benjamin netanyahu
the prime minister of israel is a
propagandist he's gonna he's gonna use
false propaganda to gain sympathy from
the world
i mean his statement was absolutely
absurd when he claimed that the muslim
mufti of jerusalem
convinced hitler to do what he did no
that's not the case
the mufti of jerusalem didn't cause
hitler to write mind comes
the the the mufti of jerusalem didn't
advise hitler to do on what what he
ended up doing to the jewish people this
is this is upset to the contrary
what we find is that many many muslims
throughout the history of islam the
muslim civilization
jewish people are saved by the muslims
so many
at so many different places in different
times this is only one example what you
showed me there right look at the
rwandan genocide go and see the role of
the muslims
in rwanda when the hutu and tutsi were
killing each other
the muslims did not become a party to
that genocide the muslim role
in rwanda during the rawandes genocide
it was absolutely amazing muslims were
saving lives
they were hiding people in masajid so
that they don't get killed by each other
right so not only with the jewish people
muslims have done it
whenever they could there are so many
examples i'm a historian
there are examples filled in my brain i
can bring
quotes upon quotes and we will run out
of time so
so this is amazing i mean once again
another muslim comes in
and saves someone who needs to be saved
okay so we got that out of the way we
cleared that
myth you know where people just try to
use that
as a red herring they try to use that
argument
oh they hate us etc etc historically
that's not the case
today you have jews who are also
speaking out against this blatant
occupation
apartheid even people like uh jimmy
carter
former american president and many
people who
just want to stand up for justice now
what's kicking a lot of this off many
people they
fall for the propaganda they get caught
in between they think oh this is just
some kind of
simple conflict and whatnot but let's
get into uh
some of the the root of the matter i
want to get your comments on
some of these clips uh some of these
videos that are out there and then
we can take it from there i'm stealing
my house and if i don't steer it someone
else is gonna steal it
no no one no one is allowed to steal it
yummy
so we we have uh
this being one of the main route
problems here even acknowledged by the
international
community by the u.n these illegal
settlements
so can you talk about this
you see all of this started after
this injustice was committed
in 1917 and it starts with the
the belford declaration when in 1917
the british foreign secretary wrote the
land of palestine away
to a people who had no right to take
that land
and then under the british mandate in
1948
uh palestine the land of palestine was
given by force
unjustly to the zionist movement
and since then the zionists have been
taking land piece by piece slowly and
steadily
they are expanding and if anyone was to
look at the map of palestine from 1948
to 2021
you will see that the territory that was
owned
or possessed by the palestinians
it shrunk in size repeatedly
systematically shrinking slowly and
these settlements
are still going on these settlers who
caught the recent
problem in sheikh jara a neighborhood of
jerusalem where they are kicking out
by fourth palestinian families that have
lived there for centuries
these these people they come from the
middle
they come from nowhere and they walk
into a house
randomly chosen and they tell the family
to get out this is not your house
this is not your land and you saw the
example of that in that video
these people are random people random
settlers
extremist jews walking into homes
and telling the palestinians to get out
this is our land
and they have yeah there you go that's
the map if you look at that map since
1948 onwards
the territory of palestine has been
shrinking look at the map in the
beginning the green
and then the second image and the third
image and look
look at the third the fourth image
that's where we are today
gaza strip is a tiny strip and
millions of people have been squeezed
into this little piece of land and on
the other hand we have the west bank
which is shrinking very fast
so what is left of palestine what is
left of palestine hardly anything
so it is being done systematically by
using settlers who are actually
occupiers settlers i mean i don't call
themselves i call them
why do you they have no right to be in
that land they walk into
palestinian homes and they tell them to
get out or you'll you'll be killed and
this is exactly how they're doing it
they are bullying people out of their
homes okay they're driving people out of
their homes
and then they don't want people to
defend their land this is absurd
this is absolutely crazy what's going on
under right under our noses
you know security council is quiet
western powers are quiet
muslim world feels powerless it's a very
desperate situation unfortunate okay
when asked you know why are they taking
the land
we get some of these these are some of
the mainstream responses
how would you answer this because you
you're also
someone who is very familiar who's
studied who spent a lot of time studying
the bible
and the jewish sources why do you steal
more and more palestinian life
why what do you steal more and more
palestinian land
these teams they steal our lives
but you came here they were living here
and you came here and
we lived here proclaimed that look at
the history not like 10 100 years
a lot of years god gave us israel god
gave us this area
we didn't still say we didn't we didn't
hate them
they hate us really i appreciate that
we have we let them live here but they
want to kill us
it's from the bible you know
your thoughts my thoughts are that this
is brainwashing this is
mental conditioning a lot of the
citizens of israel have been conditioned
and mentally brainwashed by the state
into thinking that god had promised this
land to them
there is no such promise in the bible
god had never said that this land is
given to the zionists
yeah god has never said that this land
has been given to the jewish people for
that matter right
what they refer to is a verse where it
states that the
the the land of canaan or this land
has been given to the seed of abraham
okay
so the seed of abraham means the
house of israel as well as the house of
ishmael
right because they are both abraham's
children ishmael
and jacob were both abraham's children
so if using that argument and those
those and those particular passages
then by that virtue the arabs have more
of a right on this land than anyone else
why because ishmael was the elder son
he was the elder son of ibrahim or
abraham
so if they are referring to that
particular passage in the bible
then by that virtue the arabs have more
of a right than anyone else
this this this claim is absurd it
doesn't even make sense historically
things don't happen like that
okay people have lived in a land for
thousands of years and someone turns up
and knocks the door
and says get out this land is mine bible
which was written more than 2 000 years
ago promises
promises this land to me and you know i
am
one of those people the land was
promised to this is absurd it's like
native americans turning up to your door
eddie
today one of the native americans from
the dakota territory or somewhere
you know for far west where the native
americans were driven
and whatever is left of them whatever
remains of them they come to your house
they knock the door in there eddie get
out this is my house
you took it from me two centuries ago or
your ancestors took it for me
two centuries ago would that make sense
would that make sense that wouldn't make
sense it's like
the aborigines in uh australia
going to austral you know australians
and knocking the doors and telling them
to get out this land belongs to us
uh and they actually you know what they
they do have
they do have some basis they do have
some basis to say what
what i just stated because the land was
actually taken from them
the land was but no one took the land
from these modern zionists
a lot of them come from european lands
like poland ukraine and russia
and other european countries you know
these people will never promise this
land to my knowledge
to my understanding of the bible what we
see also is
many of the uh people who refer to
themselves as zionists
they are seculars and also people who
are just atheists they don't even
believe in god
true true a lot of the zionists a lot of
the leadership in
israel doesn't believe in god they are
godless people
hence their crimes hence the fact that
they are so arrogant and they don't care
about the world what the world thinks of
them
and they they have no morals if they
were people of god
and they cared about the promise of god
then they would be godly
they would do god's work instead of
doing ungodly work
there would be a godly people look at
these people i mean we have no problem
with them
they are anti-israel they these jewish
men
who are godly men who come who come out
and
they raised their voice and they
expressed the the
the desperation on what israel seems to
be doing in their name
and i'm so happy to see them that these
people are coming out because i'm jewish
it's not just because i'm human
i stand up and condemn all what israel
is doing not just
now but doing ready for decades it's
because i'm jewish
i condemn all what's being done
supposedly in my name
and supposedly in the name of my
religion the jewish religion is being
misused
sadly and embarrassingly to commit to
justify all these crimes that are being
committed towards
against the palestinian people
now we want to make sure the
authenticity of this translation i don't
know if you
uh you obviously know the arabic
language but now this is in hebrew
it's been translated and i want to get
your take on this
i would i would advise you not to play
this clip because
we cannot confirm the translation even
if it may be true
uh in case someone turns around and says
that we are
spreading fault propaganda just to be
safe i would advise you not to play this
clip i've seen this clip and the first
question i am
whether the translation is authentic so
so let's talk about i mean
we don't need this clip we have the
actions of the state of israel we have
we we had that lady speak from our own
mouth that
okay the land has been promised to us
therefore palestinians don't have any
right here they need to get out
okay that's enough for us okay and this
clip you were about to play
says pretty much the same thing where
the kids are allegedly or apparently
saying
uh the same thing that lady was saying
earlier so we don't need to play that
clip let's confirm the translation and
we can
talk about it yes okay good good advice
thank you
what do you think have you seen this
clip
tell me if uh they're not all they want
is their country back
well that's not gonna happen i'm sorry
so you're telling me that now again
we we're not using this as something
that is representing
all of the jewish people or the
zionists or whatnot but children
innocent children deserve to die
yes because they're in the future are
terrorists
and hateful tourists okay yeah so
whether they i rather stop them
living now before they grow and have a
weapon
it's simpler oh okay so it's killing
kids is like so if you
if you had the choice you would go into
hospitals where
kids are born and kill them
everyone till the last all gaza
needs to be flit no one there no one
there
it just has you thinking because we see
children being dissipated
we blown to pieces i mean hundreds of
kids just being
you know destroyed so the mindset we
know that there's a clear verse in the
quran killing one innocent human being
doesn't matter jew christian anybody is
as
if you killed all of mankind so what do
you when you see something like this you
know the mindset you know
what's your reaction this person is
probably
you know mentally not well
or if he's mentally well then he needs
to be
looked at and western countries need to
know his name and they need to
block his entry into their countries i'm
pretty sure a lot of israelis walk
around freely
in western lands because they get free
passage
but if people who have these views of
walking around freely
i don't i don't see why isis is bad then
why is isis bad they even
i don't know if they said these kind of
things they are bad of course they are
bad we don't agree with them
we have disowned them alhamdulillah by
the grace of allah we have disowned
all people who hold such extremist views
this is extremist extremism of the worst
kind
how can you even think of killing
children it is unbelievable
how what kind of a human heart do you
have are you even a human being
this is the question i ask how can
someone who has blood running through
his veins
and considers himself to be normal talk
like this
this is brainwashing taking place within
the state of israel
where people are being made to think
like this
they are becoming extremists they are
becoming dangerous and these people have
very very dangerous weapons in their
hands and look at look look look at what
he said
that all the children of gaza they need
to be wiped out imagine
he becomes the prime minister of israel
imagine if he becomes one of those
uh influential people in israel and i'm
pretty sure there are many people like
that
is this what we are uh is this what we
are trying to promote in the world
is this what we is this why the state of
israel claims
uh that it is a democracy israel the
state of israel respects human rights if
you do
then why is this guy free if he's free
why is he still free who's talking
openly about killing palestinian
children
on screen because he feels the
protection
he needs he knows that nothing's going
to happen he knows he's in israel
if he is in israel i don't know where he
is uh he knows he's not going to be
arrested and reprimanded for this
so this is absolutely crazy
this is this is shocking how people can
talk like this in this day and age
after all the destruction we've had for
the last 30 years what have we learned
from our human experience of the last 30
years where we had
catastrophes of a grand scale we had
iraq war we have afghan war we had
vietnam we have before that we had two
world wars where millions of people died
what have we learned
as humans from those experiences things
seems to be getting worse
unfortunately in some people's mind so
this is this is shocking this is
shocking behavior and this is
brainwashing the worst kind and whoever
is
responsible for this must be held
accountable whoever is responsible for
this kind of problem
this kind of training or this kind of
thought is unbelievable
shocking if a mutman spoke like this
brother eddie if a muslim spoke like
that
from pakistan let's say from palestine
or from morocco
that would be on the news can you
imagine that can you imagine that
yes i mean i i can imagine that i can if
a crazy nutter
a muslim somewhere sitting in a in a
room somewhere
like that plastered all over the news it
would be
everything it would be airlines
everywhere it would
it would become the representation of
islam
for for a year and this is the this is
this is the this is the problem we are
facing today
in the world as a community our voice is
not being heard because we don't have
independent media
we need to have independent media so
that our voices can be heard by the
western masses
not only are not only our own masses but
even the western masses
living in the us in canada in european
lands
in australia people need to hear what
the muslim community has to say on these
things
and that's only possible when we have
independent media when we don't rely on
this so-called mainstream media
that doesn't allow our voices to be
heard yeah that's why we need the media
and influence here's uh trends are set
and even other nations can see other
nations doing good
speaking for justice and maybe this can
be a motivation for them
to get on that bad wagon instead of just
remaining complicit by being silent
so it's very amazing to see
the irish people who are really leading
in this by example i want to get your
take on this bombing of hospitals
of schools of surrey-sweden plants
it is appalling and if you want to know
what the people of palestine
say that you're speaking on behalf of
people palestine if you want to know
what the people of palestine want ask
the palestinian farmers
we've seen the most desperate and brutal
violations
of people's right to protest against
injustice against
occupation against the taking of the
very ground from under people
israel is an apartheid state
any of us have been there know that once
you know that it changes you
would you recommend that what was your
take on that you know these are people
obviously know what's going on
you know irish people are strong people
they're brave you know
and these are people of integrity who
are speaking out what do you think of
that you know
i i admire their courage and i admire
their
you know the concern and i am so happy
and it restores my hope in humanity that
there are people in the western world
who haven't been affected by this
uh consistent onslaught of media
propaganda for the last 70 years
for the last 70 years people have been
people have been made to think
that israel is zionist
zionist extremists have the right on
this land
and any palestinian who wants who wants
his land back is an oppressor
is the culprit is the criminal right
this propaganda has been going on for
the last 70s and i'm so happy to see
that people haven't been affected by
that
maybe they were affected and when they
went to palestine like that politician
was mentioning
that when you go there it changes you
when you see the oppression
when you see the concentration camp of
gaza
when you see what the palestinians have
to go through
every single day the humiliation the the
checkpoints
the the the searching okay of a people
who are
occupying your land when you when they
search you and they humiliate you
okay and they're killing you as well at
the same time
you know this kind of humiliation when
people witness this it changes them
that's why they come back and they
become like this and they are they are
open now about it
i'm very happy that there are people
like this who are coming out and they're
speaking up and this is what we need we
need
more and more moral upright
objective just people to come forward
and speak up there's no room for silence
anymore
silence is consent okay like martin
luther king said once
that uh when good people don't do
anything about evil in the world then
they are also
part of the evil they are part of the
problem so we need the good people to
come out and stop this evil
from happening uh firstly in palestine
and anywhere else for that matter we
as humans stand together for justice and
peace anywhere in the world
not only in palestine it's not only
about palestine it's about every
every other community anywhere in the
world wherever people are suffering
innocent people we stand with them and
i'm very happy to see this
restores it really restores my trust
in humanity and it really brings
uh you know a lot of peace to my heart
and my mind
when i watch these videos and and i i
really admire this work
i i want to thank these people i want to
thank these people for their effort
and uh the the concern for the
for the people of palestine we're almost
out of time we got about 10 minutes left
i mean so it hits home
into the minds the hearts of people when
we talk about injustice occupation
some people will lose their mind if
their neighbor is just right on their
border and takes an inch
of their land they're going to court you
know they're fist fighting
you know things are just going bad
so now we get really you know just
out of our mind if the electricity goes
down for you know hour
uh if when all this uh was happening
with the
food gets there's a shortage of food
you know let's just talk about that so
people understand
you know when people are treated as
subhuman this is what's happening when
on the outside they talk about okay this
is a democracy but
when they go for permits when they go
where they're made elderly are made to
stand in line
all day they have to ask to go to the
bathroom
some going in the bathroom themselves
just from going from one
area of the city that's maybe a
10-minute
walk they have to go through two three
four five checkpoints
you know on one end you have water
that's just freely available for
everyone
on the other side over here by the
palestinians you know the muslims they
or even christians who are palestinian
they are not given the same water the
same electricity the same food
people who have been working their whole
year the whole year for their livelihood
like for example to get the
olive oil you know they're stopped by
these by the
army and they're made to say certain
things you know
against their religion you know to say
um
very derogatory things against their
people etc if not
all of the the risk all of the uh
the what they've earned for the whole
year we have stories of this they've
just been you know
lost so women i mean we can go on and on
or they're humiliated you know
uh so just examples so it can hit home
so people just the average person they
have they thinking that this is just
some you know
uh fight between two neighbors it's a
conflict you know
they use these terms that's the media
manipulation but this is just
clear and blatant oppression for anyone
you know
who just looks into this a little bit uh
deeper
so give us some examples so it really
hits home so people can be like
wow this is not hard to figure out
example of what exactly
i gave a few but when people understand
when we say
occupation when we say oppression right
what does that what does that mean like
the daily a daily
a day by palestinian someone living in
this area
what they go through on a day-to-day
basis
i interviewed i interviewed a
palestinian professor
the other day uh just about four to five
days ago
and i asked him the same question
describe your life and he said
imagine living with settlers or
a checkpoint in front of you okay
there's a there's an israeli checkpoint
on top of the hill and your house is
underneath and
they can shoot you anytime at will and
they don't have to answer any questions
they are completely free to do that
right imagine if a license to kill has
been given to a criminal
to to commit crimes whenever he feels
uh he can do it or when whenever he
feels that he wants to do it
right and there is no recompense there
is no one to ask questions
imagine imagine in that living in that
in that fear
and this is what he said also he said
there are for example
uh bands of israeli thugs
i mean that's what he called them they
were like thugs walking around
the streets of jerusalem breaking
palestinian property
breaking into cars damaging houses
breaking glass right to terrorize the
palestinian people
living in jerusalem and this is recent
by the way this is last week
like in the last 10 days uh during this
conflict
that's what's been happening right what
they go through on daily basis is
absolutely unbelievable i've been to
gaza in 2010 i was in gaza i i
saw the destruction with my own eyes the
buildings were destroyed
during the bombing in 2008 when the
israelis invaded gaza
and they raised many buildings to the
ground
and they did not allow cement to go
through
so that they can rebuild gaza that's one
thing
and there were restrictions on things
like soap
things like coriander or
or mint for example on basic
items of daily youth there were
restrictions on them
imagine if your family or my family was
deprived of
toothbrush toothbrushes let's say a
toothpaste
right or something you want to use on
every single day
imagine if you were deprived okay forget
about education
medical treatment or our kidney
transplant or if you need some some
major
surgery done to yourself if you are a
patient uh you're suffering on diabetes
or blood pressure or you're a heart
patient forget about treatment
you really have to wait for a long time
for the permission to come through and
most in most cases doesn't come true
so the people of gaza in particular they
are living
in a concentration camp literally this
is how they describe it
it is a concentration camp okay and to
get the daily provisions they have to
dig
tunnels underneath underground tunnels
into egypt
and they smuggle smuggle okay i mean
smuggling is a bad word i mean
that means illegal transport uh of
things
but here in desperation they have to dig
tunnels
underground tunnels and they come out in
egypt from gaza and that's how they get
things of their daily use like their
soaps their
shampoos their pencils rubbers
things kids use toys little things
people need
for their daily use okay necessities
what we call necessities forget about
toys and luxuries
i mean things they use on daily basis
are coming through tunnels how would you
live like that
and this is happening right now as we
speak it's been happening for the last
since this conflict started in gaza
since gaza
was evacuated by the israelis a while
back
it's been happening since then so
imagine living imagine living like that
i saw people with my own eyes
living in fallen houses can you imagine
a woman with seven daughters living in a
house
the roof is half fallen due to
a bombing campaign the roof had half
fallen
and the other half was covering the
entire family a woman a widow
living with seven daughters and she's
still trying to educate them
you see what the israeli government
doesn't realize
the government of israel is not breaking
the spirit of the palestinian people
they are getting stronger by the day
just like
uh nietzsche the german philosopher said
what doesn't kill you make you stronger
okay and this is right in the case of
the palestinians
in general and the people of gaza in
particular uh
those who survive they are getting
stronger and stronger by the day
this occupation is not going to last
forever
there will have to be a resolution we
hope there is a peaceful resolution
not a devastating one you have so many
jews who are survivors of the holocaust
who speak out and they they compare this
what was done to
them by the nazis that israel is doing
to the palestinians you know
the uh sponsored uh sanction of beatings
oppression you know it's just making
life
so miserable so oppressive
just to force them to leave to get them
out doing everything possible
everything disgustingly humanly possible
that you can do
to drive them out to make it so
unbearable and liberal this is the same
thing
that the the jews talk about one in
particular is israel
who talks about this is a holocaust
survivor and he talks about them himself
and many come out and they
speak against this injustice so uh i
wanna i wanna just uh we got a few more
minutes and just a couple things i wanna
i wanna get your your um
feedback on this uh news reporter
it seems like he hits the head on the
nail
what are your thoughts it seems like
many politicians
when they are in a hole they're about to
go to jail
they also start to kick things off what
do you think about netanyahu
exploiting this political crisis as we
know he's only the acting prime minister
because of inconclusive elections
he's worried about losing office because
of possible prosecutions he might face
and that whipping up a security
situation or allowing
a very dangerous security situation to
take place maybe simply a cynical way of
saving him
what do you think about that statement
what do you think i think about that
i think that is the case uh he he will
definitely face
criminal charges because he has been
accused of corruption
despite the fact that he's ruling a
state that is that has a history of
corruption around the globe right
but ironically his own state or his own
people
within the political system of the state
of israel are accusing
him of uh corruption and there is no
doubt that he
is in in a fear of uh these prosecutions
that may begin
after he is deposed from his position if
he is deposed
and this is why he's doing what he's
doing this is exactly why
the indian prime minister narendra modi
he is often accused of inflating hatred
between the muslims of india
and the hindu right wing to to stay in
power or to come
to power right this is how politicians
some politicians evil politicians work
right they use political maneuvering
to save themselves so this is what he's
doing this is what he's doing nothing
yahoo is no exception
he's definitely doing that in my opinion
so let's uh let's go ahead and end with
this
this sad moment here um
but it doesn't stop here for us and this
is a message that
jesus moses abraham the last final
message prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him this is on the
tongue of the believers here so can you
imagine here
you know the final words someone tweeted
posted this could be our last hours as
the next
strikes may kill us whoever has grudge
against me please forgive me because i
swear i never meant to hurt anyone i
bear witness
that there is no god but allah there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
creator of the heavens and earth
allah and the muhammad is the messenger
let's talk about this statement that was
on this believer's tongue this is what
life is all about at the end of the day
you know when you see this hear this
talk let's let's end with this
absolutely amazing statement and what a
lucky man
and uh what a fortunate man rather the
prophet salallahu said
and may allah make this person one of
those people because
apparently his last words were exactly
those
and allah took him okay and allah made
him
make allah made him make that statement
so that people like us can see and
take heat so brothers and distress this
life is temporary this life is very
short
live it uprightly live it in a moral way
and always stand for justice
and never ever stand for injustice
never ever defend injustice wherever you
are whoever you may be
always stand for justice because life is
short
and we will face allah one day and allah
will question
us about our silence or even our
speaking so when you speak speak wisely
that's all my that's all i have to say
and the wisest of words are
allah and and this is uh since we're
talking about
jewish people and christians i mean this
is nothing new i mean
this is the message that moses came with
that there's no god
it's the one god and moses was the
messenger at that time
and then you have jesus came along and
in that video that we didn't
show they talk about a messiah coming
it's a whole different topic
i understand we can open it up another
time but
jesus was the messiah he was the not god
or a literal son of god
he was the one who came with allah
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the one god the creator of the heavens
and earth not worshiping a stick a stone
a bone a human being nothing under the
sun but the one who created the sun and
created the moon and all
everything in this universe so that's
the message we're upon that pure
monotheism we're the carriers of that
legacy
can you just touch upon that absolutely
moses stated the famous chama from the
book of deuteronomy
hero israel the lord our god is one lord
and this is exactly what jesus said in
the gospel of mark chapter 29 verse 12
uh rather chapter 12 verse 29 the gospel
of mark chapter 12 verse 29
when a jewish man came to jesus and
asked him master what is the first
commandment or the most important
commandment
jesus responded hero israel the lord our
god
is one lord and allah confirms this in
the quran by the way this particular
incident
is alluded to in the quran in chapter 5
of the quran chapter 5 verses 70 onward
allah alludes to this whereby allah
states
that jesus said to the children of
israel all the children of israel
worship
one god your lord and my lord
so the quran confirms these words that
are attributed to jesus christ in the
gospel of mark and also the prophet of
islam prophet
allah said the same thing to his people
say there is no one worthy of worship
except
allah and you will prosper you will
succeed
so it was the same call consistently put
out by all the prophets
and may allah bless this brother who
passed away with those words
on his tongue and he will be one of
those people who will enter the paradise
allah has promised all of us and he will
be with the prophet
who came with that call in sha allah we
pray
came to mind and we just went over a
little bit over time just reminded me of
many
uh scholars who were jewish at the time
of prophet muhammad when they looked at
his life they looked at the evidence you
know they also accepted
islam the submission to the creator
alone and not worshipping
his creation isn't that true absolutely
many
jewish scholars and christian scholars
throughout the history of the muslim
civilization accepted islam in fact
when the prophet himself was alive
abdullah bin salam was a jewish rabbi
in madina who accepted islam having seen
the prophet of islam prophet muhammad
and he confirmed that what the bible
describes
about a prophet to come from arabia has
been fulfilled in muhammad
sallallahu alaihi sallam also adi
who was a christian priest or
a learned christian also accepted islam
with the prophet in fact when the
prophet had the experience in the cave
the cave of hera
when the angel appeared to him and told
him to read and the prophet said i
cannot read i am not
learned when the prophet having had this
experience was taken to warakka bin
nowful
one of the men of scriptures in mecca
and the prophet told him his story
what happened in the cave waraqah
confirmed
this is the same angel that came to
moses same angel has come to you
and i wish i will be alive on the day
when your people will drive you out
and the people will shop will they drive
me out why what have i done
waraqah told him any man who came with
this message to his people his people
became his enemies and they drove him
out
so same will happen to you and i wish i
will be alive
when that happens so that i can support
you and waraqah accepted islam
even before the prophet of islam
preached islam to anyone
even before he himself knew that allah
has sent down revelation upon him
waraqah is telling him this angel was
sent to moses
the same angel has come to you so there
are so many examples from the life of
the prophet and
afterwards when jewish rabbis throughout
the history of islam
realized that this is the prophet that
was portrayed
in the old testament in the book of
isaiah 42 for example chapter 42
and on the tongue of jesus christ in the
gospel of john there are certain verses
where jesus talked about
a comforter and advocate uh a spirit of
truth coming in the future
who will be teaching people about the
truth all of these passages put together
they point to one man and that is
muhammad allah and many people accepted
that
no doubt thank you very much for being
with us here on the dean's show
and helping people better understand the
occupation
and what is going on in that part of the
world and
may allah grant ease and patience and
grant those from also a gemini thank you
so much
for being thank you so much